hello two legends james and jack so good
to see both of you as always
congratulations on kung fu panda the
dragon night yes it is very exciting
listen james
when you
did the first film back in 2008 did you
have any idea the legacy that this
franchise would have
and we're here in 2022 and there's a new
series so why do you think people love
kung fu panda the franchise i would like
to ask each one of them why they would
like to see us again you know through
all these years
i thought they would get tired of us but
apparently what jack black puts into
paul and i'm mr king
they fell in love with us you know and
thank goodness and this time it's
netflix coming throughout the whole
world you know
they can look at us at any time
to their command and to their love and
to their choice i think they're going to
love this one about mr ping and the pope
paul has a new adventure with a new love
wandering play and so you know he's
going to get into a lot of trouble and
of course mr payne has to bail him out
as always and
he can't do it alone he thinks he can do
it wrong but he can't
he can't do it alone and we're going to
talk about wandering blade rita ora is
incredible she has such a wicked sense
of humor jack i saw your tick tock with
rita did you just have the best time
working alongside someone like her
you know the thing about rita yeah she's
super talented
musically and acting chops and funny
like you say
but also the magic ingredient she's down
she's uh
she's down to clown around which i love
it's the best quality you can have as a
performer in my opinion
not being afraid
to look like a fool because a lot of
times that's the road to magic
yeah it takes a little courage
it does take a little courage and let's
talk about courage and i mentioned tick
tock there you in your speedo you on the
toilet you know 14.5 million followers
jack on tick tock is pretty incredible
um are you surprised the amount of
people that want to visit your tick tock
and see you in the speedo because you've
inspired me to rock my speedo next month
in barcelona
i have to say i i'm starting to regret
the toilet one i'm thinking about taking
about removing that from the internet
i'm glad you reminded me i'm gonna scrub
that off of my tick tock
but uh
yeah i uh i have had a fun
little explosion of internet excitement
uh and it's kind of been a cool little
rocket blast for me
um i recommend it
yeah i saw that you actually did a tick
tock
with james so james i think that you
could be
maybe the biggest tick tock star in the
world now that you've done one with jack
have you considered possibly joining the
platform
i'm you know it's funny uh but funny you
bring up that subject i watched jack
do his tic tac and i said i got to do
one of those you know
i was going to do one
and uh all of a sudden this whole thing
of the uh what is it the uh everywhere
everything all that one's all the
publicity and this one the kung fu panda
thing
you know i have to drop it and pull but
now i have to bring it all back to life
again but why are we talking about
tick-tock
because it's huge everyone loves tick
tock it is a great promotional tool
right
yeah i'll do it in a mandarin right
i need
i'll get that chinese audience that i
can outdo jack somehow
you know james i want to celebrate you
because last month you received a star
on the hollywood walk of fame which i
think jack and i can agree on
is so well deserved at 93 years old how
does it feel to be at this point in your
life and receive an honor like that
well
as i said uh previously if they wait any
longer it would be post-mortem
[Laughter]
so i don't know you know
thank goodness
my mother made me eat those herbs when i
was young
and still now i can do kung fu
anything you want me to do like i'm
still looking to do the master kung fu
of the world you know so uh you know
and then through the uh breakdance of
all kinds
i love to do that lion dancing at my uh
star uh performance at the when they put
in the star walk of flame i said i gotta
do something different so i hired a
group of uh
lion dancers and i dance with them so
that's the first time anybody
did anything different on the star walk
of fame instead of being just i accept
this award i want to do something and
party
you